among all the trainees I have tated this
level samara ranks in the top five
percent and on overall performance
Samir Chauhan reads a letter of
recommendation from a doctor who
supervised him as a medical volunteer in
the United States that's the only way
this canadian-born graduate of a foreign
medical school could get work experience
with the kovat 19 crisis placing heavy
burdens on Canada's hospitals he's
asking why young doctors with foreign
qualifications find it almost impossible
to work in their own country
many of us are qualified very
knowledgeable and skilled and we don't
want those skills and knowledge to go to
waste you want to use it to serve our
country dr. Rafat alice wad rand
Baghdad's largest pediatric hospital
then worked in muscat he and his wife a
prominent dentist in both Iraq and Oman
came to Canada in 2013 to make sure
their children had a stable future
neither has been able to work Rifat
would have to retrain as a GP which he
can't afford to do so he's driving for
uber to pay the bills governments in
Canada defer to medical licensing
organizations which maintain they have
to be cautious about admitting doctors
trained in other countries but many say
foreign training could also be an asset
to Canadian health care experience on
Terios medical licensing body told Al
Jazeera it's looking into the issue but
has yet to make any changes in its
residency programs one of Canada's most
multicultural cities Brampton home to
many currently unemployed foreign
trained medical personnel is leading one
of many campaigns to usher more of them
into the healthcare system the
infrequency of the test and the lack of
hospital residences that are made to
available to the foreign trained
doctors so we have over 1,700 doctors
who passed all the tests but only 350
doctors actually got a residency last
year so that is a huge waste of human
capital and potential experts sake Ovid
19 will continue to challenge the
medical system here for months possibly
years making the need for more frontline
health care workers ever more acute
Daniel Locke al-jazeera Toronto